thought recently about life and um you
know work will demand everything from
you people will demand everything from
you your family will demand everything
from you and and it might be a pleasure
but you only you know it's hard to get a
bit of your time so when I showed you
that with Danny about the
meditation perhaps it will be the best
four minutes or whatever it took of
whole
week tell me it might be and and
so with all the things I've done in my
life and I have been busy and I
still my iido never lets me down because
you see I can do that and it's 100% for
me and and I I can't sort of explain it
but what I'm saying is I can look now
back on
life and say thank goodness I put iido
before all the other demanding things
right because all demanding things will
suck you up and they'll demand even more
it's a bit like the monkey mind you know
and you'll go yeah you talk to my boss
you know and I say no you must thought
your boss
because you know none of you know if
tomorrow you're going to have a bad
accident and never walk again you don't
know if you're going to get Co again and
be laid up like that that man who just
died after a few years I'm not trying to
be miserable I'm just saying that iido
to me is a very very sacred art and it's
because I in me I found everything I
needed to find for me it was my Escape
patch you know I can come here I can put
this penguin suit on and I can be
somebody different so so um so I'm
encouraging you to not even if you don't
want to do it all you life I'm encourage
you to work out that you do need time as
an individual you need you need precious
time and if you don't take it or or work
away so you can get it you'll never get
it right your partner possibly won't die
when you die they weren't born when you
were born so you're pretty much on your
own through life